how's it going bros my name is pierre de
ba today i'm going to get a tattoo and
you're coming along I'm going to London
to get it and I'm going to walk you
through the whole thing it should be a
life-changing experience I'm so excited
let's go so we're driving to London it's
about two hour drive I booked this
appointment like three months ago
I'm so excited the artist is so cool I
usually don't show when I get my tattoos
but I thought today would be the perfect
time and if you never gotten a tattoo
before you coming you will get to come
along and get a feel for it
so how about that I got a focus on
driving I'll see you later
we got one hour left to go I wanted to
talk a little bit
if you're getting a tattoo for the first
time things that you might want to know
number one is I think is finding what
you want to get as tattoo at least the
first time you get one
it's really hard to decide it gets in
your head and you think you have to have
this reason of why you put ink in your
body like you have to justify it way
more the first time and then the second
time you get it you're like well I just
want this tattoo I don't really care but
I would still do a lot of research on it
personally and think about it a lot and
I would make sure that I find a good
artist do a lot of research on the
artist and a lot of research on they
aren't and eventually you'll feel
comfortable enough to do it so another
thing I know you're thinking of it and
it's if you never got a tattoo and it's
the paint does it hurt no yes I think it
hurts but it's not unbearable pain you
can go through it if I can do it anyone
can do do it I think maybe the first
tattoo you get you can pick a spot where
it will hurt less for example your arm
when you have a lot of fat it won't hurt
as much
is it hurt yeah that's true so you won't
be too bad I promise you you can do it
they make it if you have a good artist
they will make it comfortable for you
and put like ointment and I don't
know how they do it I'm still gonna cry
like a little baby today I'm going to it
I feel like I have to disclaim though
that I am by no means an expert and you
should sell do your own research this is
just based on my experience
we got 10 minutes left
that was a long drive oh my god I'm
getting a little nervous
I think that's normal I'm really excited
I but like I said I I've been waiting a
long time for this tattoo
what are you getting boots oh you're
just gonna see there's a two-part light
that we're going to is song blue I never
been there but it's supposed to be
really good and the artist is called
Luciano I'll link them in the
description if you're curious I found
this guy on Instagram and I just love
his style that's why I went with it and
he happened to be in London this time
otherwise I would have just gone with
Brighton cuz I hate going in London but
yeah we're gonna eat something now if we
can find a place I don't know I always
decide on the spot the spot my tan those
are for kids once I get out yeah this is
cool glad we did that
oh my god you're gonna die all right
that's the place
good job Marcia I'm not sure if we're
allowed to film in there probably not in
a lot of places they don't like you
where we're going in I'm nervous I don't
know why is we filling in like legal
paper very exciting is it really cool
shock really
I gotta know that you're coming by now
yeah I want you to get your I really
like this one all right
finished it took two hours right I feel
really really good
yeah well I mean oh you can't see it
okay
he was really nice a tattoo artist it
was a good experience and their shop was
really nice too they recognized me so
they gave me a t-shirt which I
appreciate thank you very much we're
going back here yeah yeah
okay we're back in Brighton oh man
that's a lot of driving four hours in
total it was worth it though I'm so
happy with the tattoo we're gonna what
are you doing we're gonna clean it up
now so you see how that's like cuz I
think a lot of people don't realize that
it takes a while for it to heal so very
interesting we'll see you there it's
been a few hours you ready to see
something really gross yeah I think I
left it on a little too much it didn't
look like this an hour ago but now it
really huh you need I need to clean it
here's the part where you're so far away
you really should just listen to your
tattoo artists and not me because
everyone will tell you different and
it's really important that you clean
your tattoo properly that's all I'm
saying here I'm not saying follow mine
all right whatever blood look at that
that is pretty gross it's important
that it kept clean no bacteria yeah
treated like an open wound it takes a
lot of time for your tattoo to heal not
two weeks yeah until then you have to
keep taking care of it cleaning it and
it's kind of like part two of the tattoo
I guess part one is actually getting it
I'm kind of like over careful with with
Washington because I don't want to
up the tattoo but it looks good I'm
happy with it there's no damage so far
can you shed clothes that I'm very very
happy with that clean town pet that
it still hurts I forgot about the best
thing the cocoa butter now I hate creams
but cocoa butter is that you put
some cocoa butter it smells so good and
you rub that with a cocoa butter oh
yeah don't wanna you gotta cover it all
very gentle
Matt see I can you can the me and cocoa
matter of you cook of butter I love you
let me smell it it smells good right
smells lovely Michael
all right dad this has been my first day
of tattoo experience hope you enjoyed
coming along was it educational
absolutely thank you for coming along I
hope you enjoyed it and even if you're
into tattoos or not I don't know but
that's it for now thanks for leaving a
like I'll see you Bruce in the next
video and my chat thank you for being
such a great camera woman and as always
stay awesome brush serve and when you
get beard meters thanks buddy give her
something stronger we need that crunch
come on as you wish
she been riding